that is a dress billy thank you for
making good on your promise last night
oh yes
it's so nice to see you you look very
pretty and you look
wow you are giving me marilyn monroe
vibes young lady is that what you were
going for a little bit yes
i mean you were you've got to still be
on a high from last night
congratulations
and tonight what an elegant affair you
are also coaching what does it mean to
you it's it's
like the most insane honor you would not
believe i feel like
i'm in a dream
i feel like i'm like
tripping
you said that you were feeling a lot of
nerves
yeah like good ones though like nothing
literally not one bad i just am like
this is the most exciting thing i've
ever done it could be the corset too
jeff it could it could but you're giving
it to us how many people had to help you
get ready
oh
dude probably like 20 i don't know so
many people oh my god look how
[Music]
this is our first time so we're super
excited about this
doesn't she look amazing
it's really exciting i just feel honored
to be here
[Music]
oh that was such a wonderful thing to
get to do the hollywood bowl was such an
important venue to us growing up in los
angeles and paying tribute to our
hometown was such a fun experience and
yeah i think to me
the places that you're from the places
that you spend time in they bleed into
all of your work and in your personality
in a way that you might not think about
all the time but to spend time and think
about how the place that you came from
made you who you are is a fun experience
and we just had a great time i mean it's
incredible you guys are at a place like
the hollywood bowl together
[Music]
it was fun everybody everybody at the
hotel is running around all stressed and
i'm like this is a party like
i think we're just going to a party so
i'm really excited to be here and you
guys are going to be on the ultimate
party next year what are you most
looking forward to when it comes to
getting back on tour i think to us
there's nothing more important than our
relationship with our audience and our
listeners and our fans and so just
getting to be there for them you know
part of the the one of the many things
that was heartbreaking about clovid was
just feeling like we weren't able to be
there for our audience physically so
getting to be there for people
physically is just so exciting we can't
wait to play more shows